Ce que je conteste, c'est ce que tant de gens en concluent,
à savoir que nous sommes tous fichus
parce que nos problèmes sont insolubles
et nos gouvernement inutiles.
Pourquoi dis-je cela ?
Je ne suis pourtant pas très optimiste par nature.
Mais le catastrophisme permanent des media
focalisés seulement sur les problèmes plutôt que sur les solutions
m'a toujours profondément dérangé.
J'ai donc décidé il y a quelques années,
(en fait, je suis journaliste)
de voir si je pouvais faire mieux.
en voyageant autour du monde et en demandant aux gens
si et comment ils s'étaient attaqués
à leurs gros défis économiques et politiques.
Ce que j'ai trouvé m'a stupéfait.
Il se trouve qu'il existe des signes remarquables de progrès
souvent dans les endroits les plus inattendus,
et ils m'ont convaincu que nos grands défis globaux
pourraient ne pas être si insolubles après tout.
Il n'y pas seulement des solutions théoriques ;
ces solutions ont été essayées.
Elles ont fonctionné.
Et elles nous donnent de l'espoir.
Je vais vous montrer ce que je veux dire
en vous racontant comment trois des pays que j'ai visités
-- Canada, Indonésie et Mexique --
ont surmonté trois problèmes réputés insolubles.
Leurs histoires sont importantes car elles contiennent des outils utilisables
non seulement pour ces problèmes particuliers
mais aussi pour de nombreux autres.
Quand la plupart des gens pensent au pays où je vis aujourd'hui, le Canada,
s'il leur arrive seulement de penser au Canada,
ils pensent « froid », ils pensent « ennui », ils pensent « politesse ».
Ils pensent que nous disons trop souvent « désolé » avec notre accent amusant.
Et tout cela est vrai.
(Rires)
Désolé…
Mais le Canada est aussi important
Pour avoir triomphé d'un problème
qui déchire actuellement de nombreux pays :
l'immigration.
Pensez-y, le Canada est aujourd'hui l'une des nations les plus accueillantes
Même en comparaison à d'autres pays accueillants.
Son taux d'immigration par habitant est quatre fois supérieur à celui de la France
et son taux de résidents nés à l'étranger
est double de celui de la Suède.
Cependant, le Canada a accueilli
dix fois plus de réfugiés Syriens l'année dernière
que les États-Unis.
(Applaudissements)
Et en ce moment même, le Canada en accueille plus encore.
Et si vous demandez aux Canadiens
ce dont ils sont le plus fiers à propos de leur pays
ils classent « le multiculturalisme »,
un gros mot dans la plupart des autres pays,
En seconde position,
Au dessus de « hockey »…
Hockey.
(Rires)
En d'autres termes, au moment où les autres pays
dressent frénétiquement de nouvelles barrières pour tenir les étrangers dehors,
les Canadiens en veulent encore plus.
Maintenant, voici la partie vraiment intéressante.
Le Canada n'a pas toujours été comme ça.
Jusqu'au milieu des années 60, le Canada avait une politique migratoire explicitement raciste.
Ils appelaient ça « White Canada »
et comme vous voyez, ils ne parlaient pas que de la neige.
Alors comment ce Canada est-il devenu le Canada actuel ?
Bien, malgré ce que vous dirait ma mère, en Ontario,
la réponse n'a rien à voir avec la vertu.
Les Canadiens ne sont pas intrinsèquement meilleurs que quiconque.
L'explication réside en l'homme qui prit la direction du Canada en 1968,
Pierre Trudeau, qui est aussi le père du Premier ministre actuel.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qu'il faut savoir à propos de ce premier Trudeau
c'est qu'il était très différent des précédents dirigeants canadiens.
C'était un francophone dans un pays usuellement dominé par son élite Anglaise.
C'était un intellectuel.
Il était même assez groovy.
Je veux dire, sérieusement, le gars faisait du yoga.
Il fréquentait les Beatles.
(Rires)
Et comme tous les hippies, il pouvait parfois être exaspérant.
Mais quoi qu'il en soit, il a initié l'une des plus progressistes
des transformations jamais vues dans aucun pays.
Sa formule, comme le l'ai appris, est en deux parties.
D'abord le Canada a bazardé ses vieilles règles raciales d'immigration,
au profit de nouvelles règles, indifférentes aux couleurs,
qui mettaient l'accent sur l'éducation, l'expérience et la maîtrise de la langue.
Ce qui a résulté en un net accroissement des chances
qu'un nouveau venu devienne un contributeur de l'économie.
Ensuite, Trudeau a créé la première politique au monde
de multiculturalisme officiel pour promouvoir l'intégration
et l'idée que la diversité était la clef de l'identité du Canada.
Dans les années suivantes, Ottawa a continué de promouvoir ce message,
mais simultanément, les Canadiens ordinaires ont bientôt commencé
à percevoir les bénéfices matériels et économiques du multiculturalisme
tout autour d'eux.
Et ces deux influences se sont bientôt combinées
pour créer le Canada passionnément ouvert d'esprit d'aujourd'hui.
Tournons-nous vers un autre pays, et un problème plus difficile encore,
l'extremisme Islamique.
En 1998, le peuple Indonésien est descendu dans les rues
et a renversé son ancien dictateur, Suharto.
Ce fut un moment formidable,
mais aussi effrayant.
Avec 250 millions d'habitants,
l'Indonésie est le plus grand pays à majorité musulmane du monde.
C'est aussi un pays chaud, énorme et indiscipliné,
composé de 17 000 îles,
où se parlent près d'un millier de langues.
Nous disions que Suharto avait été un dictateur,
de la pire espèce.
Mais c'était aussi un tyran plutôt efficace,
qui a toujours pris soin de tenir la religion hors de la politique.
Aussi, les experts ont craint que, sans son maintien ferme,
le pays n'explose,
ou que des extrémistes religieux s'emparent du pouvoir,
et changent l'Indonésie en une version tropicale de l'Iran.
Et c'est exactement ce qui a semblé se produire au début.
Lors des premières élections du pays, en 1999,
les partis Islamistes recueillirent 36% des voix,
les îles s'enflammèrent
tandis qu'émeutes et attentats firent des milliers de victimes.
Depuis lors, pourtant, l'Indonésie à pris un virage surprenant.
Alors que les gens ordinaires sont devenus plus pieux à titre personnel
-- J'ai vu beaucoup plus de foulards lors d'une récente visite
que je n'en avais vu une dizaine d'années plus tôt --
les politiciens du pays ont suivi la direction opposée.
L'Indonésie est aujourd'hui une démocratie très décente.
Et ses partis Islamistes ont même perdu du terrain
depuis un pic d'environ 38% en 2004
jusqu'à 25% en 2014.
En ce qui concerne le terrorisme, il est maintenant extrêmement rare.
Et même si quelques Indonésiens ont récemment rejoint DAESH,
leur nombre est faible,
bien moindre en proportion de la population
que le nombre de Belges.
Essayez de penser à un autre pays à majorité Musulmane
qui puisse en dire autant.
En 2014, je suis allé en Indonésie demander à son président,
un technocrate à la voix douce nommé Joko Widodo,
« Pourquoi l'Indonésie est-elle florissante quand tant de pays Musulmans se meurent ? »
« Ce que nous avons compris, » m'a-t-il répondu,
« c'est que pour résoudre l'extrémisme, nous devions d'abord résoudre les inégalités »
Les partis religieux d'Indonésie, comme les partis similaires ailleurs,
tendent à se focaliser sur des thèmes tels que la pauvreté et la corruption.
Alors c'est ce que Joko et ses successeurs ont fait également,
coupant l'herbe sous le pied des Islamistes.
Ils ont aussi durement réprimé le terrorisme,
Les démocrates Indonésiens ont retenu une leçon essentielle
des années noires de dictature,
cette leçon est que la répression produit seulement plus d'extrémisme.
Alors ils ont mené leur guerre avec une délicatesse extrême.
Ils ont utilisé la police plutôt que l'armée.
Ils n'ont détenu de suspects que s'ils avaient assez de preuves.
Les procès étaient publics.
Ils envoyèrent même des imams libéraux dans les prisons
pour convaincre les djihadistes que la terreur est contraire à l'Islam.
Et tout ceci a spectaculairement fructifié,
en créant un pays qui était inimaginable il y a 20 ans.
À ce point, mon optimisme devrait, j'espère,
commencer à être un peu plus compréhensible.
Ni l'immigration, ni l'extrémisme Islamique ne sont insolubles.
Passons au dernier de ces voyages,
au Mexique cette fois.
De nos trois histoires, celle-ci est probablement la plus surprenante,
puisque comme vous le savez tous,
ce pays se débat avec tant de problèmes.
Et pourtant, il y a quelques années, le Mexique a fait une chose
dont nombre d'autres pays de la France à l'Inde en passant par les USA
ne peuvent encore que rêver.
Il a mis fin à la paralysie politique qui le grippait depuis des années.
Pour comprendre comment, il nous faut revenir à l'année 2000,
lorsque le Mexique est finalement devenu une démocratie.
Plutôt que de consacrer leurs nouvelles libertés à lutter pour des réformes,
les politiciens du Mexique les utilisèrent pour se battre entre eux.
Blocages parlementaires, et problèmes spécifiques du pays
-- drogue, pauvreté, crime, corruption --
explosèrent littéralement.
La situation devint si grave qu'en 2008,
le Pentagone alerta sur le risque d'effondrement du Mexique.
Puis, en 2012, cet homme nommé Enrique Peña Nieto est parvenu
d'une façon ou d'une autre à se faire élire président.
Il n'inspirait pas une grande confiance au premier abord.
Certes, il était séduisant,
mais il venait du PRI, vieux parti Mexicain corrompu,
et était un coureur de jupons notoire.
En fait, il apparaissait tel un beau gosse sans épaisseur
que les femmes le surnommaient « bombón »,
lors des meetings de campagne.
Mais bientôt, ce même « bombón » a surpris tout le monde
en élaborant une trêve
entre les trois partis en guerre dans le pays.
Et au cours des 18 mois suivants, ils ont ensemble passé
un lot de réformes incroyablement complet.
Ils ont forcé l'ouverture du Mexique en étouffant les monopoles.
Ils ont libéralisé son secteur énergétique déliquescent.
Ils ont restructuré son système éducatif défaillant, et bien plus encore.
Pour prendre la mesure de ce qui a été réalisé
essayez d'imaginer le Congrès des USA passant une réforme sur l'immigration,
une réforme sur le financement des campagnes et une réforme bancaire.
Toutes simultanément.
C'est ce qu'a fait le Mexique.
J'ai rencontré Peña il y a peu, et lui ai demandé comment il s'y était pris.
Le Président m'a gratifié de son fameux sourire scintillant --
(Rires)
et répondu que la réponse courte était « compromiso », compromis.
Bien sur, je lui ai demandé des détails,
et la réponse longue était essentiellement
« compromis, compromis et encore compromis. »
Voyez-vous, Peña savait qu'il devait bâtir la confiance rapidement,
alors il a approché l'opposition quelques jours seulement après son élection.
Pour écarter les pressions des intérêts particuliers,
les réunions étaient restreintes et secrètes,
et plusieurs des participants m'ont dit plus tard que c'était cette intimité,
et quelques tournées de tequila,
qui a permis de bâtir cette confiance.
Ainsi que le fait que toutes les décisions aient requis l'unanimité,
et que Peña ait accepté de passer certaines des priorités des autres partis
avant les siennes propres.
Santiago Creel, sénateur de l'opposition, m'a déclaré :
« Écoutez, je ne prétends pas être spécial, ni que quiconque est spécial,
mais ce groupe était assurément spécial. »
La preuve ?
Peña a prêté serment, le pacte a été tenu,
et le Mexique a recommencé à avancer pour la première fois depuis des années.
Bueno.
Ainsi nous avons vu comment ces trois pays
ont surmonté trois de leurs plus grands défis.
Et n'est-ce pas formidable pour eux ?
Mais qu'est-ce que cela apporte au reste d'entre nous ?
Bien, en étudiant ces exemples et quelques autres succès,
le redressement du Rwanda après la guerre civile,
la réduction des inégalités au Brésil,
la préservation de la croissance en Corée du Sud, plus forte et longue
que dans aucun autre pays du monde,
j'ai noté quelques points communs.
Mais avant de les décrire, il me faut faire une mise en garde.
J'ai conscience, bien sûr, que chaque pays est unique.
Et qu'on ne peut simplement transposer ce qui a marché dans l'un
vers un autre et espérer que ça marchera aussi.
Et que des solutions spécifiques ne marcheront pas toujours.
Vous devez les adapter comme les circonstances changent.
Cela dit, en réduisant ces histoires à leur essence,
vous pouvez tout à fait extraire quelques outils commun de résolution de problèmes
qui fonctionneront dans les autres pays
et dans les salles de conférences
et toutes sortes d'autres contextes.
Primo, embrasser les extrêmes.
Dans chaque histoire que nous avons vue,
le secours survient à un instant de péril vital.
Ce n'est pas une coïncidence.
Prenez le Canada : quand Trudeau a eu à affronter deux dangers imminents.
D'abord en dépit du besoin cruel de bras
de son vaste pays sous-peuplé
sa source favorite de travailleurs blancs, l'Europe,
venait de cesser de les exporter, s'étant relevée de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale.
L'autre problème était la longue guerre froide Canadienne
entre ses communautés Française et Anglaise
qui venait de devenir une guerre chaude.
Le Québec menaçait de faire sécession,
et les Canadiens se tuaient entre eux à travers la politique.
Maintenant, les pays affrontent des crises en permanence, n'est-ce pas ?
Ça n'a rien de spécial.
Mais le génie de Trudeau a été de comprendre que la crise Canadienne
avait fait sauter tous les obstacles qui bloquent usuellement les réformes.
Le Canada devait s'ouvrir. Il n'avait pas le choix.
Et il lui fallait repenser son identité.
Là non plus, il n'avait pas le choix.
Une opportunité qu'on ne rencontre qu'une fois par génération
de briser les vieilles règles et d'en écrire de nouvelles.
Et comme tous les héros, il était assez intelligent pour la saisir.
Secundo, il y a de la puissance dans les idées banales.
Une autre similitude saisissante entre les bons résolveurs
est leur pragmatisme.
Ils prendront les meilleures solutions quelle que soit leur provenance,
sans laisser des détails
tels qu'un parti, une idéologie, ou un sentiment leur barrer la route.
Les démocrates Indonésiens furent assez intelligents
Pour s'approprier les meilleures promesses de campagne des Islamistes.
Ils invitèrent même des radicaux à se joindre à leur coalition.
Ce qui horrifia nombre de laïques.
Mais en contraignant les radicaux à participer au gouvernement,
ils ont rapidement mis en lumière leur incompétence,
et les ont mêlés à tous les compromis plus ou moins propres
et aux mesquineries qui sont le lot quotidien de la politique.
Et ceci a tellement écorné leur image qu'ils n'en sont jamais revenus.
Tertio
Satisfaire tout le monde la plupart du temps.
J'ai dit que les crises offraient aux dirigeants des libertés hors du commun.
C'est vrai mais la résolution de problèmes requiert souvent plus que de l'audace.
Elle impose aussi de faire preuve de retenue,
juste quand c'est la dernière chose dont vous avez envie.
Trudeau : quand il a pris la direction du pays,
il aurait pu satisfaire le cœur de son électorat :
la communauté Française du Canada.
Il aurait pu satisfaire une partie des gens tout le temps.
Et Peña aurait pu utiliser son pouvoir contre l'opposition,
comme c'était la tradition au Mexique.
Mais il fit le choix d'embrasser ses ennemis,
forçant son propre parti au compromis.
Et Trudeau a contraint tout le monde à cesser de penser en termes tribaux
et à voir le multiculturalisme, et non le langage ni la couleur de peau,
comme la quintessence Canadienne.
Personne n'obtint tout ce qu'il voulait,
mais chacun obtint juste assez pour que le pacte tienne.
Alors à ce stade, il se peut que vous pensiez,
« OK, Tepperman,
si les solutions sont là comme vous le répétez,
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas plus de pays qui les appliquent ? »
Elles ne requièrent pas de pouvoirs spéciaux.
Aucun des dirigeant dont nous avons parlé n'était un super-héro.
Ils n'ont rien accompli tout seuls,
et ils avaient tous beaucoup de défauts.
Prenez le premier président démocrate Indonésien,
Abdurrahman Wahid.
Ce type avait si peu de charisme
qu'il lui est même arrivé de s'endormir
au milieu de son propre discours.
(Rires)
Histoire vraie.
Ceci nous apprend que le véritable obstacle n'est pas l'inaptitude
ni les circonstances.
C'est une chose beaucoup plus simple.
Faire de grands changements implique de prendre de grands risques,
et prendre de grands risques est effrayant.
Surmonter cette peur requiert des tripes,
et comme vous le savez,
les politiciens avec des tripes sont dramatiquement rares.
Mais ça ne signifie pas que nous, électeurs
ne devons pas exiger le courage de nos dirigeants politiques
C'est même pour celà que nous les plaçons aux commandes
Et vu l'état du monde aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas d'autre choix.
Les réponses sont là,
mais il nous appartient
d'élire plus de femmes et d'hommes
suffisamment courageux pour les trouver,
se les approprier
et les faire fonctionner.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)